Львів — дуже красиве місто насправді.
І тут вже дуже велика історія
розвитку культурного середовища.
Ми називаємо наше місто
культурною столицею України.
Тут стільки культурних подій відбувається.
Привіт!  Слухайте, можна, будь ласка,
на сцені цокнути світло чи ні?
Червона лампочка — світиться.
— Світить, світить.
— Так?
Так, так.
Добре, зрозуміло.
Ні-ні-ні... Є?
А, є. Все, є.
Все, дякую. Йду на сцену.
Палац Хоткевича почали створювати 1926 року,
коли мітингом вийшли
працівники-робітники термальники,
яким не було простору,
де вони могли б проводити свій вільний час.
Приміщень тоді вільних не було,
і на їхніх зборах вирішили: «Що ж ми будемо чекати,
давайте якось своїми силами».
Десять років працівники кожного місяця по 1 %
своєї зарплатні відкладали на окрему купочку.
І так вони назбирали більше половини суми.
За 10 років їх дофінансували.
І так зробили першу частину клубу трамвайників.
Клубу проведення культурного дозвілля.
Палац починає район Підзамче.
Те, що до колій, — це центр.
Те, що за коліями, — це вже не центр.
Район Підзамче вважався промисловим,
там були переважно заводи.
Люди важко працювали.
І для них культурний осередок
був знаковим місцем.
Об'єкт є надзвичайно модним,
відповідає тенденціям того часу.
Це є об'єкт чесної архітектури.
Чому вона чесна? Тому що нічого
не заховане за деталями, за декораціями.
Він навіть не потинькований.
Ми чітко бачимо всі перемички над вікнами,
Хоч вони й іншого кольору, ніхто не намагався
їх закрити, приховати — усе видно.
Єдиним декором є рельєфна кладка.
Все ж таки, вони будували палац,
тому мала бути якась така річ, яка відрізняє
його від звичайних тоталітарних об'єктів.
Найцікавіше те, що з 1934 року і до сьогодні
палац не змінив свого призначення:
він як надавав культурні послуги 1934 року,
так і зараз він надає культурні послуги.
Ми прийшли сюди новою командою
і починаємо якісь зміни.
Завжди всі ставляться дуже
з обережністю і настороженістю, бо:
«Прийшли нові люди. Що вони хочуть? Закрити? Вигнати?»
Але ми не можемо понищити,
тому що тут уже є історія.
— Добрий день.
— Ви всі зайняті?
— Ще немає всіх.
— Ще немає всіх? А де ви всі так довго?
— То заходьте.
Тут музика 20 років уже живе.
У 1996 році тут відбувалися
репетиції гурту «Брати Гадюкіни».
А потім...
У 2000 році тут заселилася...
Ну, не наша банда,
а ті гурти, до яких я мав відношення.
У нас є в стратегії чотири напрями:
інфраструктура, сенси, команда і комунікація.
Наші сенси: сюди входили всі наші колективи,
це і надання культурних
послуг для дітей і підлітків.
А друга складова —
це всі події, які ми тут організовуємо.
Інфраструктура — найважчий процес.
Будь-яку складову історії варто зберігати.
Ми добудовувати нічого не збираємося тому,
що це є пам'ятка архітектура.
Вона є вже повноцінна.
Вона історично цілісна так,
як вона склалася.
Зараз відбувається процес
реставрації цієї пам'ятки.
Багато внутрішніх ремонтів ми вже зробили.
Оновили сучасні студії, класи.
У колективів є свої приміщення.
Зараз ми на даху будівлі
палацу ім. Гната Хоткевича,
яка перебуває на стадії реставрації.
Також у нас є в планах реконструкція вивіски.
Ми її хочемо залишити такою як є.
Між цими всіма новими будинками
ця вивіска дуже класно виглядає.
Ми хочемо, щоб вона світилася.
Вона колись світилася.
Тут, у штаті, навіть був
працівник освітлювач вивіски,
який приходив в певну годину вмикав
і вимикав на вечір освітлення вивіски.
Коли ти вникаєш у цю історію,
що воно от таке має бути,
ти її вже не хочеш міняти.
Просто хочеш її ревіталізувати,
відновити, додавши чогось нового,
але залишивши історичну цінність,
яка тут є.
Сучасне завдання — використати
тут кожен квадратний сантиметр,
щоб роззосередити людей і
дати їм якийсь зручніший простір,
накрити якусь кількість функцій,
які виникли вже в наші часи,
сучасні, для розвитку дітей чи молоді.
У 2018 році коли ми прийшли сюди з командою працювати,
ми насамперед почали вивчати історію.
Вивчали історію самого палацу,
будівництва і що тут було.
Потім ми [вивчали] сам палац Хоткевича
і хто такий Гнат Хоткевич.
Хоткевич тут ніколи не був.
Але класно те, що тут є і театральна студія,
і танцювальна студія,
і студія образотворчого мистецтва,
і офіс «Львів — Місто літератури ЮНЕСКО».
І власне, все те, що тут відбувається,
тим і був Гнат Хоткевич.
Він був і громадським діячем,
й інженером, і театралом,
і письменником, і поетом.
Воно так дуже перегукується.
Зараз концертний зал
перебуває на стадії реставрації.
Все, що можна реставрувати і
відновити до того стану, ми відновимо.
Тут прекрасна акустика.
Людина, яка сидить на балконі або в кінці зали,
чує все так само як людина, яка сидить у перших рядах.
Тут було облаштовано екрани,
які працювали для покращення
акустики та реверберації.
І ось такі додаткові елементи, які ми
зараз у напіврозібраному стані спостерігаємо.
Сцена глибока.
Коли в оперному театрі зайняті сцени,
а їм треба десь проводити репетиції,
то вони часто орендували зал у нас.
Тому що глибина і ширина [сцени] дозволяли
проводити оперні вистави навіть тут.
Я сподіваюся, коли ми відновимо сцену, то відновляться
і всі наші виступи — наших колективів насамперед.
1970–1990-ті роки, коли панували совєти,
культурна опозиція, як її можна назвати,
збиралася, власне, в палаці Хоткевича.
Наше підвальне приміщення
було заповнене різними гуртами.
На той час вони вважалися неформальними,
зараз — це одні з кращих гуртів України.
Це були «Брати Гадюкіни», «Мертвий Півень»,
тут розпочинав співати Чубай.
22 роки як Пікардійська Терція
має тут свою репетиційну базу.
Телефонують відомі
співаки того часу — 1990-х років, —
«Пані Лесю, мені дали ваш номер телефону.
Я колись у вас на сцені виступав. Можна ще раз виступити?»
Та, звичайно, можна!
Ми можемо перейти зараз у наш хол.
Це у нас була виставка
присвячена Гнату Хоткевичу.
Оцифровані його роботи.
Виставку доповнювали роботи дітей
нашої студії образотворчого мистецтва.
Як ми вже говорили про те,
що 1924 року розпочався спільнокошт,
у 2019 році ми теж спробували зробити спільнокошт.
І на початку 2020 року на сучасних платформах
ми збирали кошти на реконструкцію цього простору.
І ми назбирали 82 тисячі гривень в час найсуворішого
карантину — і, власне, вийшов такий простір.
Верхній простір, який ми відкривали, —
був простір візуальних видів мистецтва.
А нижній простір — це будуть скульптури і графіка,
і різні види об'ємного мистецтва.
І мультимедійні експозиції.
Оскільки ми є комунальна установа міста,
то можемо надавати простір безкоштовно.
Це дуже актуально
для молодих митців-початківців.
Ми їм даємо приміщення
і технічне оснащення, вони тут виставляються,
так вони тут починають свою кар'єру.
Ми зробили open-call,
і одразу зголосилися 23 художники.
У нас майже на два роки розписана діяльність.
Це теж перегукується з тою історією,
коли тут зароджувалися гурти,
колись ті художники, які вийшли від нас,
[згадуватимуть]: «У нас же тут була перша виставка».
Львів великий.
Між тими маленькими пам'ятками архітектури,
де проживають люди давно-давно,
заселяються нові люди —
і всім треба буде жити, комунікувати.
І палац Хоткевича має стати тим культурним центром,
куди будуть сходитися всі мешканці цього району.
Зараз такий час, що всі втомлені роботою.
Всі дуже втомлені буденщиною,
така рутина.
І ось такі культурні, духовні збагачення
нехай на годину раз на тиждень
людині буде набагато легше потім
переключатися на свою роботу.
Важливо зберігати не просто будівлю,
а будівлю з людьми.
Люди творять культуру, люди
творять музику, це все від людей [йде].
Вони йдуть сюди за цим духом, за цією атмосферою,
бо тут народжується творчість.
Для того, щоб вони могли творити,
їм треба комфортні умови. Всім.
І ми над цим комфортом якраз і працюємо найбільше.
Колись через скількись-там років скажуть:
«От цей період ревіталізації, відновлення,
набуття сенсів в установі зробила ця команда».
Тому що я не сама,
і це дуже класно, коли є команда.